Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Vous écoutez Septante Minutes Avec. Le monde est un peu bizarre en ce moment. Ouais, d'ailleurs attendez, cette musique est beaucoup trop joyeuse.
Voilà. Oui, donc pour ceux qui nous écoutent depuis le futur, je publie cet épisode le 2 avril 2020, en pleine période de confinement et de crise liée au Covid-19.
J'espère que tout va bien pour vous et que vous restez bien enfermés chez vous. J'en parlais avec une camarade autiste l'autre jour, pour certains d'entre nous, ces changements sont vraiment durs.
Pour moi au contraire c'est assez reposant, donc je suis assez chanceux à ce niveau-là. Donc surtout, ne vous faites pas trop d'inquiétude pour moi.
En ce qui concerne ce podcast, le virus chamboule pas mal les choses évidemment. Je sais pas encore très bien comment je vais faire pour trouver des invités sans sortir de chez moi.
Je vous reparle de tout ça à la fin de l'émission. Mais en attendant, j'ai eu la chance de pouvoir compter sur mon amie Fanny pour me dépanner.
Fanny Ruwet est humoriste, elle fait du stand-up depuis environ un an et demi. Elle a commencé à animer des émissions de radio pour la RTBF en 2015.
Et aujourd'hui, elle fait des chroniques dans Snooze, sur Pure et aussi dans La Bande Originale sur France Inter. Enfin, elle anime aussi un podcast d'interview, un peu comme celui-ci, mais en moins bien, qui s'appelle Les Gens Qui Doutent.
Si vous connaissez pas, allez l'écouter, c'est sur le même site que Septante Minutes Avec. Tous les liens sont dans la description.
Fanny a un cerveau bizarre comme je les aime et j'étais très content de bavarder avec elle pendant 70 minutes.
Ensemble, on a parlé de comment elle vit le confinement, comment elle approche le stand-up, ce qu'elle en retire, l'évolution de sa carrière, tout ça, et surtout son rapport aux gens, à leurs mensonges et au monde qui l'entoure.
C'est parti. Le confinement, ça se passe comment pour toi ?
Ben en fait ça dépend, j'ai vraiment des sortes de roller coaster entre : « C'est incroyable, tellement de temps pour travailler sur mes projets, je sais même pas par où commencer tellement j'ai des idées et tout » à « À quoi bon ?
De toute façon je le terminerai pas en vie ce confinement, rien n'a de sens ». Donc c'est pas toujours évident.
Je me prends des gros bad, mais voilà, c'est...
Ouais. Sur Twitter, tu disais que ça te donnait envie d'écrire beaucoup plus, comme ça, ça permettrait de rentabiliser cette période de difficulté.
Ouais.
T'arrives à écrire du coup ?
Mais ça dépend. Ça dépend. Genre hier, j'ai passé une journée trop bien. J'ai avancé sur trois projets qui m'amusent énormément.
Mais à côté de ça, deux jours avant, j'ai juste passé ma journée à regarder des séries et à me dire : « Rien n'a de sens ».
Donc, ça dépend. Je dirais que... En fait, j'sais pas. Au début, je me suis beaucoup tâtée. J'ai beaucoup essayé différentes façons de m'organiser.
Au début, je m'étais fait... parce que j'ai besoin de m'imposer une certaine rigueur. Du coup, j'avais fait un petit planning, vraiment comme quand j'étais en blocus.
Donc pendant mes révisions, j'avais vraiment tel jour, de telle heure à telle heure, je bosse telle matière et tout.
Donc là, j'avais fait ça avec mes projets. Et en fait, ça m'a déprimée, mais de fou parce que je me sentais obligée en fait de faire des choses que j'aime et du coup, ça les gâchait.
Tu vois ? Et donc...
Et d'habitude, t'es quelqu'un qui fonctionne avec des plannings, des horaires, des trucs comme ça ou pas du tout ?
Bah... J'ai des to-do lists tout le temps. Et donc c'est pas exactement la même chose, mais j'arrive d'habitude à m'imposer des choses.
Et là, non, ça m'a vraiment déprimée. Donc j'ai,
maintenant, ce que je fais, c'est que les choses que je dois faire obligatoirement parce que c'est mon travail, genre les chroniques et tout chaque semaine, vu que j'ai des deadlines claires,
bah je les fais en temps et en heure, mais tout le reste, je suis un peu en mode : bah
j'ai différents projets, là, j'en ai trois, quatre en cours, bah qu'est-ce que j'ai envie de faire maintenant ?
Qu'est-ce qui me ferait plaisir ? Et donc j'avance là-dessus jusqu'à ce que j'en aie marre et puis après, je vais lire et puis je fais autre chose.
Et en fait, je suis beaucoup plus efficace comme ça, c'est beaucoup plus stimulant, beaucoup plus amusant. Et voilà.
Mais ouais, il m'a fallu vraiment du temps pour trouver un peu comment m'organiser pendant le confinement parce que j'ai pas l'habitude de passer autant de temps chez moi, et j'ai pas l'habitude de,
ouais, d'avoir des journées comme ça où je bouge pas, où je peux pas aller bosser dans un café parce que je sais que chez moi, c'est pas toujours hyper efficace.
C'est réapprendre des choses.
Tu disais t'as pas l'habitude de sortir, 'fin t'as pas l'habitude de pas sortir. C'est quelque chose que tu vas mal vivre ?
T'es quelqu'un qui a besoin de sortir ou t'es plutôt un oiseau d'intérieur ?
Je suis assez surprise parce que pour moi, rester chez moi tout le temps, c'était l'Eldorado quoi, c'était mon rêve.
Bah oui, c'est comme ce que disait Dan, travailler depuis chez soi et générer des revenus en pyjama.
Oui, y avait un truc... et puis j'ai tellement été à l'étranger, à gauche, à droite, à jouer quasi tous les soirs en ce moment que j'avais trop envie de passer du temps chez moi.
Et en effet, j'adore ça, mais pas H24 sans avoir l'opportunité de sortir, en fait.
Ouais, tu te sens prisonnière.
J'ai vraiment eu des phases où je pétais des câbles. Ouais, ouais, vraiment, je me sentais seule et... 'fin je sais pas, c'est chaud quoi, on n'est pas fait pour ça et ça se ressent à fond au bout d'un certain moment.
Moi, je suis fait pour ça.
Ouais.
Pas trop de différence avec mon mode de vie normal.
Mais ouais, mais des frustrations aussi quand même hein. Mais globalement, 'fin toi, c'est plus chaud parce que faire du stand-up, faire des tournées, c'est ton revenu, tu peux plus le faire.
Ouais.
Comment tu vas gérer ça ?
Bah j'ai un trou de deux mois dans mes rentrées d'argent quoi. Donc clairement, c'est pas ouf. Maintenant, j'ai du backup parce que je suis du genre à mettre vraiment beaucoup de côté parce que je suis une grosse flippée de la vie.
Donc ça va. Puis y a le gouvernement qui met des choses en place pour qu'on soit pas trop dans la dèche.
Le paiement des impôts sur le revenu et les cotisations sociales sont reportés, donc.
Ouais, puis y a les trucs de droits passerelle ou quoi et tu...
Ouais, c'est ça.
...touches équivalent chômage pendant deux mois et 'fin voilà. Et donc a priori, financièrement, c'est OK, tu vois.
Mais j'en parlais hier justement avec Marina Rollman de ce stress en fait de me dire : « Je suis en train de ne pas gagner de l'argent ».
Et j'ai l'impression d'être obligée tout le temps d'avoir des petits, comment dire, des petits objectifs court terme.
Genre je me dis : « Allez, il faut que je pousse pour faire une chronique pour tel truc, pour tel truc et tout, pour gagner des micro-sommes et avoir des, genre des chroniques et tout ça pour un peu
qu'il se passe quelque chose sur mes réseaux sociaux et que comme ça je remplis mes salles pour le mois de mai parce que ça commence à me stresser et tout », et tu vois.
Et de remplir à chaque fois des micro-étapes qui sur le long terme ne servent à rien, mais c'est parce que ça me rassure.
Tu cherches les micro-sommes ou tu cherches les micro-doses de dopamine ?
Bah surtout la dopamine en fait. Surtout le fait de me rassurer sur le fait que je vais remplir mes salles en mai. Et ouais, me rassurer sur le fait que je gagne quand même de l'argent et donc j'me sens un peu valorisée, j'me sens avancée en fait.
Parce que c'est un peu se dire : « OK, je vais écrire, je sais pas, un scénario », bah c'est intangible. Et du coup t'as pas de reward au bout d'un moment, tu vois.
Tu te dis pas : « Oh putain, comment j'ai bien avancé, maintenant j'ai fini. À la semaine prochaine ». Non, là c'est un truc qui est tellement de longue haleine que t'as pas cette dopamine régulièrement.
Et j'ai vraiment du mal à me concentrer sur les projets longs à cause de ça quoi.
Ça t'angoisse ?
Ouais, à fond. Faut que je sente que j'avance en fait.
Et globalement aujourd'hui quand tu fais des tournées, quand tu montes sur scène en France, en Suisse, en Belgique, au Québec, tu en retires quoi ?
Tu sens ta carrière avancer ou bien c'est aussi le plaisir en soi de monter sur scène ? Tu conserves encore ce plaisir-là ou pas ?
Bah ça dépend en fait. Là j'ai beaucoup enchaîné les choses, 'fin genre en décembre, janvier et tout.
Et là c'était un peu trop et je perdais justement ce plaisir de monter sur scène et tout parce que c'était tellement un rythme effréné que j'écrivais plus de nouvelles choses.
Je faisais que jouer et faire des chroniques et j'étais claquée et tout. Et donc j'avais plus... genre ça tournait trop bien en fait, j'avais plus besoin de réfléchir.
Des fois, j'étais vraiment en mode pilote automatique, c'était affreux.
T'étais dans ta zone de confort.
Ouais, c'est ça tu vois et c'est chiant. Genre je vais pas tourner ce spectacle pendant deux ans comme ça tu vois.
Comme Alex Vizorek.
Non, 10 alors, 10, 10 ans. Et là 'fin genre en février j'ai rajouté 10 minutes de nouveau matos, 'fin dans le spectacle.
Et là de nouveau j'ai retrouvé cette excitation de tu sais pas si ça va marcher, tu sais pas si ton anglais est bon, t'essayes des choses en impro et tout et ça c'est, putain c'est trop bien quoi.
Et à chaque fois ça me fait me rappeler pourquoi j'aime bien le stand-up.
Et du coup pourquoi est-ce que t'aimes bien le stand-up ?
Tu sais pas.
J'aime bien... mais en fait c'est trop de choses systémiques. C'est genre j'aime bien le fait d'essayer de transformer des choses qui a priori sont pas drôles en trucs comiques.
J'aime bien le fait que tu te jettes un peu dans le vide en fait, parce que dans ta tête c'est fantastique, mais peut-être les gens ils vont se dire : « Mais qu'est-ce que tu fais meuf ?
» Donc y a un peu ce, ouais, ce frisson, cette dopamine.
Ce stress, ouais, ce thrill, ouais.
Et puis le moment où tu trouves la bonne idée. Putain, mais c'est le truc le plus incroyable que j'ai ressenti quoi. C'est tu te dis : « Mais putain oui, c'est ça ».
Tout s'imbrique. C'est im... j'avais toutes les lettres pour faire un Scrabble, mais elles étaient pas dans le bon ordre et maintenant tout s'aligne.
Et ces moments-là, mais c'est ouf quoi.
Ce que tu dis là, le moment où tu trouves la solution, c'est pas spécifique à la comédie ?
Non.
...du coup qu'est-ce qui spécifiquement dans la comédie te rend, j'allais dire te rend heureuse, mais c'est peut-être une exagération.
Bah ça me stimule en tout cas, c'est... en fait y a un truc dans la comédie qui est très, très logique, très mathématique et je déteste les maths, mais ça m'amuse en fait de trouver la bonne formulation.
T'es quelqu'un de plutôt carré, un peu comme un ordinateur ?
Bah en fait genre j'ai tendance à me considérer comme ça, mais...
Non, non moi aussi.
J'suis pas toujours très lucide.
OK.
Donc voilà, donc y a cet aspect trouver la bonne formulation, trouver la bonne... ouais le truc qui va faire prémisse plus bonne chute égale vanne drôle tu vois et...
Ouais mais tu vois, mais encore une fois, des trucs mathématiques, logiques, j'ai envie de dire mais pourquoi est-ce que t'es pas, ben n'importe quel autre métier de mathématique et logique ?
Parce que c'est plus comique.
OK.
J'aime bien rire Guillaume, que veux-tu ?
OK, ouais c'est ça que j'essaie de comprendre. Mais 'fin tu vois y a cette théorie qui revient souvent surtout aux États-Unis qui est celle du comique triste.
Tu vois les gens cassés, déprimés, marginalisés qui montent sur scène pour un peu compenser une certaine souffrance. Y a pas mal de bouquins là-dessus.
C'est vrai d'après toi, ça te parle ou ?
Bah ça dépend, je pense qu'y a plusieurs... moi je pense que tous les comiques que j'aime bien, oui c'est totalement ça.
C'est des gens qui ont été...
T'aimes pas Jerry Seinfeld ?
Écoute, non.
Non. Et puis ouais y a plein d'humoristes que j'aime vraiment pas parce que j'ai l'impression qu'ils n'ont rien à dire et qu'ils veulent juste le média comédie plutôt que le message derrière et ça, ça me saoule, moi ça me stimule pas du tout.
'Fin d'un côté y a des choses teubées qui me font énormément rire hein. Genre The Office, clairement c'est pas pour le message que je regarde.
Mais en général ce qui m'intéresse le plus c'est des gens qui racontent des choses ouais douloureuses, des gens qui ont eu des vies, qui ont vécu des choses,
genre Patton Oswalt qui raconte la mort de sa femme, le moment où il a dû l'expliquer à sa fille.
'Fin putain c'est... t'arrives à me faire rire avec des choses au sujet desquelles je peux pleurer quoi. Ça c'est un art.
C'est ça qui me stimule à fond en fait.
C'est exactement ça que j'ai ressenti y a, c'était quoi, y a deux, trois ans, j'sais plus, quand...
Moi j'étais allé voir pour la première fois, la toute première fois Dan Gagnon en rodage et que c'était le lendemain du jour où sa femme a eu son IVG.
Ouais.
Et genre il monte sur scène, genre il a pas écrit son texte pendant des mois quoi. Il monte sur scène avec ça, avec ce vécu et il a juste, 'fin c'était...
Mmh.
...il a réussi à être comique avec un truc super grave.
Ouais.
J'étais super impressionné. Je pensais que c'était comme ça tous les soirs. Puis j'étais très déçu.
Ouais, mais Dan Gagnon est très décevant comme garçon.
Yes. 'Fin non, je sais pas. Mais euh, ouais, bah ouais, mais d'ailleurs j'ai écouté son nouveau podcast.
Il m'a fait un shout out dans l'épisode d'hier, c'était très gentil.
Ah cool.
Voilà, ça c'était ta réaction de personne qui s'en fout : « Ah cool ».
Ah non, mais j'ai pas encore écouté ceux des deux derniers jours.
Bah voilà, mais il est très... y a un peu un de ces côtés, il lit l'actu et il monte son point aussi à lui, il fait : « C'est pas comme ça que ça devrait être ».
« Vous êtes des cons ».
Voilà, c'est ça.
Blague.
Ouais, mais en général, t'as encore un syndrome de l'imposteur ou pas ?
Ça se travaille, ça va mieux parce que j'ai eu des validations extérieures que je n'espérais même pas.
Donc y a un côté un peu, voilà j'ai...
Genre qui ?
Bah des trucs genre à partir du moment où France Inter m'appelle pour que je fasse des chroniques, à partir du moment où Montreux m'invite, 'fin genre tu te dis voilà, c'est,
c'est leur boulot en fait d'aller chercher des gens qui sont comiques.
Et puis je me suis aussi mise dans le mood... moi, je fais de mon mieux quand on me propose un projet, quand on m'engage pour quelque chose, je fais du mieux que je peux, je m'investis, je fais vraiment le mieux possible.
Mais si mon meilleur, c'est pas suffisant, bah c'est plus mon problème en fait. C'est la personne qui m'a engagée qui a foiré son truc. Donc...
T'as toujours été comme ça ?
Non, non, non, c'est récent.
Ouais.
Parce que voilà, à un moment c'est... ouais, j'ai plus envie d'avoir cette responsabilité en fait.
Y a des moments où on t'a dit qu'on n'était pas content de ce que tu produisais et où tu l'as mal vécu ?
Avant que tu fasses ce changement-là.
Je pense que c'est jamais arrivé, non, parce que j'ai tellement cette angoisse qu'on dise : « You're not good enough » que je m'arrange toujours pour-
Tu comprises.
...viser le 9 sur 10 comme ça, au pire, j'ai un 7 quoi.
Mais du coup ça m'étonne parce que t'as fait ce changement d'approche, ce changement d'angle en te disant : « Je rationalise.
Si les gens sont pas satisfaits, tant pis, j'ai fait de mon mieux ».
Mmh.
Mais qu'est-ce qui t'a obligé à faire ce changement-là ?
J'aime pas être stressée. Et je me suis dit : « Mais putain, j'aime pas ce sentiment ».
T'es vraiment bizarre comme personne.
Bah écoute, moi, je suis marginale hein, que veux-tu ? Et du coup non, j'aime pas ressentir ça. Donc je me suis dit : « Bah OK, je vais éliminer ce sentiment en faisant en sorte que ce problème devienne le problème de quelqu'un d'autre ».
Et, ouais, donc tu parlais de cette validation extérieure, de France Inter, de Montreux, etc.
Aujourd'hui, tes ambitions, les trucs que t'aimerais atteindre, c'est quoi ?
Mmmh. Bah, je t'avoue, c'est toujours un peu flou parce que tout est allé tellement vite-
Mmh.
...que en général, les choses se sont réalisées avant que j'envisage qu'elles puissent arriver, tu vois. Genre Montreux, je m'étais dit : « Peut-être un jour ça arrivera, mais pas avant l'année prochaine ».
Et puis là, ils m'appellent. Et puis France Inter, je m'étais dit : « Peut-être un jour, inch'Allah, dans trois ans, quatre ans ».
Et puis ils m'appellent donc je-
Ils ont vraiment baissé la barre hein.
Ouais, c'est ça. Ils n'ont plus aucune exigence ces gens. Et du coup,
je sais pas, c'est tellement bizarre cette façon dont les choses sont arrivées et tout que là, mon objectif à moi sur le court terme, c'est de,
de faire en sorte que le spectacle soit terminé, vraiment peaufiné pour-- bah logiquement, la deadline, c'était avril pour les dates à La Nouvelle Scène.
Et puis là, vu que Corona tout ça, bah c'est le mois de mai, juin genre.
et puis voilà, une fois que le spectacle, j'aurai vraiment plus à y toucher, bah je pense que j'essaierai d'écrire quelque chose, un truc un peu plus ambitieux en termes de forme et de-- je sais pas encore.
Là, j'ai deux, trois idées de scénarios dans les tiroirs. J'ai deux, trois trucs du style, de gens avec qui j'ai envie de travailler.
Donc, je pense qu'on va avancer-
Des scénarios, tu penses à des mini-séries ? Tu penses à des podcasts ? Tu penses à quoi ?
Là, on a un podcast sur le feu. J'ai une sorte de, ouais, mini-série, que je suis en train de cogiter avec deux copains.
Et voilà, on a quelques petits projets comme ça. Mais l'idée, là, ce serait surtout d'apprendre à travailler en fait comme ça, d'apprendre à travailler en groupe,
d'apprendre à avoir une rigueur dans les projets comme ça, d'apprendre un peu-- là, je suis en train de lire des bouquins sur justement l'écriture de scénarios, ce genre de trucs.
Parce qu'en fait, toute cette-- c'est assez systémique en fait. Je me rends bien compte que là, depuis que j'ai écrit le spectacle, il est construit de manière à ce que les éléments que j'ai mis au début reviennent vers la fin et tout.
Et je sais que ça m'a beaucoup appris à écrire une histoire sur toute sa longueur.
Mais à côté de ça, je sais que là, en lisant des trucs sur la scénarisation, ça va m'aider aussi à progresser dans le stand-up parce que je vais voir les choses de manière différente, tout ça.
Là, j'ai regardé un masterclass de Judd Apatow sur l'écriture comique. Bah ça m'aide aussi pour les scénarios. 'Fin c'est vraiment plein de choses en fait, plein de domaines dont je peux me nourrir et qui vont se former une synergie. Donc-
Donc c'est assez cool, c'est assez stimulant en fait d'aller un peu piocher dans tous les domaines pour,
pour essayer de faire les choses les plus complètes et les plus inattendues possible en fait, parce que c'est l'avantage aussi quand on n'a pas trop les codes de chaque média, c'est qu'on a tendance à les mélanger parce qu'on sait pas que ça se fait pas.
Mmh. Et de manière générale, quand tu parles de bouffer des documentaires, lire des livres sur la comédie, les trucs de-- je sais que t'as lu celui de Chris Gethard y a pas longtemps.
Mmh-mmh.
Tu dirais que c'est genre ton intérêt spécifique, genre le truc dans lequel tu peux te plonger pendant des heures et des heures et des heures et pas en avoir marre et être complètement passionnée à fond ?
Non, pas du tout parce que j'ai la capacité de concentration d'une belette.
Ah ouais.
Donc non, c'est très compliqué. Justement, j'ai beaucoup de mal à rester focus sur un truc. Il faut vraiment que je me bloque.
C'est marrant parce que je te vois tout le temps poster des photos de bouquins sur Instagram et des trucs. Je me dis : « Mais elle arrête pas de lire ».
Ah non, c'est juste qu'à chaque fois que je lis, je le poste.
Ouais, ouais, mais c'est marrant que tu dises ça parce que, en fait pendant le coronavirus, j'avais téléphoné à un psychiatre y a genre des mois parce que je pensais que j'avais des troubles de l'attention.
Mmh-mmh.
Et on m'a donné rendez-vous genre en 2021, genre méga file d'attente et tout. Et puis pendant le coronavirus, on m'a téléphoné, on fait : « Ouais, en fait, bah plein d'annulations.
Est-ce que vous voulez venir dans une heure ? » J'fait : « Ouais ». Et en fait, ouais, ils m'ont diagnostiqué un truc,
trouble de l'attention ou quoi et ça me handicapait à fond parce qu'à chaque fois que je voulais lire un bouquin pour le podcast notamment,
je lisais trois lignes et puis ça me faisait penser à 10 000 autres choses et je me perdais dans mon imagination, je faisais le lien, je réfléchissais à d'autres trucs.
Et puis, après 10 minutes, je retournais sur mon livre, je fais : « Merde, j'ai lu trois lignes en 10 minutes ».
Donc c'était absolument horrible. Mais du coup-
Mais du coup, tu parles au passé, ça veut dire que t'as trouvé une solution miracle ?
Bah, ils m'ont prescrit un truc, ben c'est la Ritaline quoi, 'fin ou l'équivalent.
Et je vais aller chercher à la pharmacie, tout à l'heure. Je te dirai si ça marche.
Ah ben ouais, fou.
Je t'en dealerai un peu-
Oh yes !
...un peu au-dessus du prix avec la prescription.
Oh là là !
Y a pas de petit profit.
Le crime s'organise.
Ouais, mais globalement, c'est quoi ta-- la meilleure scène que t'aies faite, par exemple ? Ton meilleur souvenir sur scène, plutôt.
Mon meilleur souvenir sur scène ? Je sais pas. C'est-
Y en a pas ?
Ben en fait, y en a pas de particulier, tu vois. Y a juste des dates où je me dis-- je sais que ma dernière au Kings en février, elle était dingue.
Je sais pas pourquoi.
Je pense que-- attends, c'était quoi le truc
? Ah oui, je pense que c'est parce que je testais du nouveau matos et j'étais tellement concentrée sur ne pas foirer le nouveau matos que j'étais méga relax pendant tout le reste parce que je me disais : « Mais ça, c'est bon, je connais ».
Et du coup, c'était hyper chill, hyper agréable.
T'étais en mode automatique, ouais.
Non, non, non, pas du tout. Justement, j'étais en mode tout va bien. Pour l'instant, je connais, donc on va juste plaisanter un peu avec le public, et ça va être bien.
Et j'étais très sûre de moi, très détendue et donc, c'était cool.
Et donc quand tu descends d'une scène comme ça qui s'est vraiment bien passée,
t'as plutôt l'impression d'avoir donné quelque chose aux gens ou bien que c'est plutôt eux, leurs applaudissements, leurs rires qui ont nourri quelque chose chez toi ?
Mmh, ils ont nourri mon besoin perpétuel de validation.
OK, donc plutôt, ils ont nourri quelque chose chez toi plutôt que l'inverse ?
Non, en vrai, non. Non, je pense que c'est plutôt l'inverse quand même parce que je sais que le spectacle est fait de manière à ce que, 'fin les gens ont tendance à se dire : « Putain, c'est OK d'être nul des fois ».
Et that's fine, tu vois, y a un peu un truc de-- genre je raconte plein de choses nulles qui me sont arrivées et j'essaye de faire des blagues avec ça.
Et je pense que ouais, y a un truc un peu dédramatiser les choses pas ouf. Et puis voilà. Et puis en général, les gens, ils sont quand même contents d'avoir rigolé un petit peu pendant une heure quart.
Donc voilà, mais moi, oui, ça m'apporte des trucs.
Des trucs ?
Je sais pas, le fait de voir que des gens connectent avec ce que je raconte en fait, de savoir que je suis pas la seule à-
Mmh.
...à angoisser sur des trucs, à-- et ouais, le, se sentir moins seule en fait.
Donc quand tu parles du fait que tu t'es fait inviter par erreur à l'anniversaire d'un garçon quand t'avais 13 ans et que t'avais des pâtes, des macaronis dans tes poches-
Mmh-mmh.
...et que les gens rigolent, t'as l'impression que tu te sens validée-
Je pense qu'ils ont jamais-
...moins étrange ?
Ben en tout cas, y a un peu ce truc de tout le monde a déjà été dans une situation où clairement, t'es un peu la merde de la pièce, tu vois.
Et clairement, t'es pas assez bien pour les gens autour de toi. Et c'est un peu ce sentiment de-- ouais, on a tous eu un moment où on n'était pas assez, où on n'était pas assez bien et c'est chouette de se dire qu'on n'est pas les seuls.
OK. On se connaît, on se connaît, on se connaît dans la vie, on fait des podcasts ensemble. T'es plutôt une meuf qui aime bien avoir la paix, prendre du temps pour toi.
C'est ce qu'on disait tout à l'heure, le fait de rester dans ton appartement, a priori, on aurait tendance à penser bah, c'est plutôt ton environnement.
Et depuis que je te connais en fait, t'as étudié la communication, t'as fait de la radio. Je t'ai rencontrée parce que t'organisais des concerts à Bruxelles.
Maintenant, tu fais du stand-up, tu fais des podcasts et tu fais tous ces trucs où tu parles aux gens, où tu passes beaucoup de temps sur les réseaux sociaux à exprimer des trucs, à parler aux gens.
Mais en fait, mais en vrai, 'fin tu détestes les gens, non ? 'Fin, je comprends pas.
Mais en fait, ma vie n'a aucun sens hein. Genre j'ai fait des relations publiques. What the fuck ?
Ouais.
Ça n'a aucun sens. J'ai voulu être attachée de presse. Non.
Et tu sais toujours pas expliquer pourquoi ?
Mais non, ça n'a aucun sens. Je-
Parce que Dan a fait la même chose et il est aussi comme ça.
Ouais, mais ouais non, je sais pas. Je-- sur papier, c'était une mauvaise idée dès le début et j'ai sauté à pieds joints.
C'est quoi ? C'est parce que la communication, c'était un mystère pour toi que t'as voulu t'améliorer là-dedans ou non ?
Du tout. C'est juste que je me disais : « Bah écoute, j'aime bien la musique, j'aime bien les projets culturels et j'ai très envie d'essayer de les promouvoir pour que plus de gens les découvrent.
» Mais y a tout l'aspect aller sucer la teub des journalistes pour qu'ils en parlent, que j'avais pas trop calculé.
Et en soi, je regrette absolument pas parce que j'ai appris plein de choses qui me servent aujourd'hui dans mes études, 'fin dans la vie.
Donc les études, je regrette absolument pas, mais en effet, les débouchés, c'était pas du tout pour moi. Donc heureusement que c'est un domaine assez large où tu peux facilement rebondir sur plein de choses différentes.
Mais ouais, les six mois où j'ai fait ce taf-là, ça m'a bien flinguée quoi.
Comment t'expliques le fait que t'es une meuf de nature introvertie qui aime passer du temps seule, isolée et que tu fais que des boulots
bah, où tu parles à des gens, où t'es en contact avec des gens, où tu les fais rire, où tu fais des trucs pour eux, tu passes beaucoup de temps sur les réseaux sociaux.
Comment, comment enfin-
Déjà, je pense qu'y a une notion de-- souvent, quand je fais des trucs où je parle aux gens, ils peuvent pas me répondre.
Ouais.
La radio et le podcast, le stand-up et tout, y a très peu d'interactions quand je suis sur scène parce que c'est : je parle et vous écoutez and that's the deal.
Mh. Je sais que Thomas Wiesel, il vit très mal le moment où les gens viennent le voir une fois qu'il est descendu de scène.
Toi, tu le vis bien toi ou pas ?
Bah disons que c'est toujours bizarre, tu vois, c'est...
Mh. Des inconnus qui viennent te parler comme s'ils connaissaient ta vie.
Bah déjà, souvent, c'est un peu le cas en fait, parce que je parle tellement souvent de ma vie réelle dans les chroniques, sur scène et tout, que les gens, ils connaissent plein de choses.
Des fois, ils me sortent des trucs et je suis là : « Mais putain, comment tu sais ça ? » Puis je me rappelle que j'en ai déjà parlé.
Moi, je me rappelle d'un jour où j'étais venu te voir. Je crois que c'est la dernière fois que je suis venu te voir, au King's, je sais pas combien de temps.
Et à un moment donné, tu dis : « Ouais, je suis avec mon amoureux, ça se passe super bien. » Et y a une meuf derrière nous qui crie le nom de ton copain à ce moment-là.
Et j'étais avec lui, on se retournait, on regardait, mais c'est qui cette meuf ? Et c'était très étrange.
Ouais, c'est assez bizarre, mais c'est-- bon d'un côté, je fais quand même le tri entre ce que j'accepte de donner comme info et ce que je donne pas quoi.
Maintenant, y a des fois les gens en fait ont du mal à cerner cette barrière et du coup, y a des gens qui me posent des questions totalement, pas déplacées, mais un peu trop personnelles, genre en DM sur Instagram et tout.
Et moi, je suis là : « Mais putain, non en fait. » Donc ouais, je sais que quand on parle de soi, de manière parfois assez perso et tout, les gens ont du mal à faire les distinctions, ouais.
Ouais, donc tu nuances ce truc en disant : tu fais beaucoup de choses en communication vers les gens, mais tu le vivrais pas bien si c'était dans les deux sens quoi.
Bah disons que j'aime bien choisir-- j'ai pas de patience avec les gens. Et donc j'aime bien choisir les gens que j'écoute parler.
Mh.
Et donc, ouais, c'est rare. J'ai pas énormément d'amis, j'ai pas énormément de séries que je regarde. J'ai pas, voilà-- 'fin j'aime bien vraiment choisir les gens qui m'intéressent très fort.
Et j'écoute ça, mais c'est tout quoi. Le small talk et les trucs de parler pour parler, ça me casse les couilles et je trouve que c'est une perte de temps sans nom.
Classique.
Et donc voilà.
Pourquoi t'es autant sur les réseaux sociaux du coup, d'après toi ?
Je pense que c'est un mélange entre je trouve que c'est un moyen très chouette de faire des choses comiques. Ça plus le fait que bah, je cultive un peu-
genre mes réseaux pour que les gens viennent me voir en spectacle et que d'avoir plus de poids la prochaine fois que je vais proposer un projet à une chaîne ou quoi.
Et parce que je dis : « Ouais, mais j'ai, je sais pas, 40 000 personnes qui me suivent sur Internet », donc y a quand même un peu d'engouement derrière.
Et aussi un mélange de besoin de dopamine et de validation court-termiste quoi.
Mh. Donc c'est à la fois un outil professionnel et en même temps un truc un peu addictif.
Ouais, mais totalement. Mais ça, c'est vraiment problématique pour moi en ce moment quoi.
Mh. Ouais, parce que je parle de ça parce que c'est toi qui en parlais un peu sur Instagram pour dire : t'as envie de te sevrer.
Mh.
Du coup, t'y arrives ?
J'ai quelques trucs qui m'aident à mieux le gérer, genre des applis à la con, genre Forest qui bloque ton téléphone pendant 40 minutes.
Et puis, si t'y vas quand même, ça tue un arbre. C'est des trucs. Mais genre, c'est même pas un vrai arbre, tu vois.
Si au moins c'était un vrai arbre et que tu recevais la vidéo de l'arbre en train de se faire hacher, là, oui. Là, ce serait hilarant.
Mais non, c'est même pas un vrai arbre. Donc c'est vraiment teubé. Mais ce truc psychologique de un peu de honte, si t'arrives même pas à tenir jusqu'aux 40 minutes, bah c'est quand même efficace.
J'ai lu quelques trucs sur le sujet, j'ai regardé deux, trois vidéos et tout et j'essaye de-- j'ai pas de juste milieu en fait.
Soit je ne peux pas toucher à mon téléphone le matin et genre plus ça dure dans la journée, mieux c'est. Soit c'est mort quoi.
Si je check juste Instagram une fois, c'est mort. Je vais y aller toute la journée. Donc je me force à ne pas y aller le matin et à
me dire : « OK, jusque 13, 14 heures, tu travailles, tu ne fais que ça, tu te concentres et après, tu fais ce que tu veux, tu t'amuses, tu check ton téléphone si tu veux », mais
faut que je me fixe vraiment des moments sans quoi.
Et t'y arrives ?
Ça dépend des jours. Ça dépend parce que des fois, je me dis : « Ouais, mais il faut que je partage le podcast que j'ai fait hier, machin ».
Alors que putain, c'est tellement une non-excuse, mais
Ouais.
...mais voilà, ça dépend.
Tu partages mes podcasts sur le compte Instagram de... J'aime bien quand tu parles, tu dis : « Mais oui, il faut que je fasse la gueule contre moi ».
À cause de toi, j'échoue.
Sorry, not sorry. 'Fin globalement, quand je parlais de toi comme une personne plutôt introvertie, tout ça, t'es pas la seule comme ça.
'Fin quand je prends cette description comme ça, je pense à des gens comme Thomas Wiesel, Florence Mendez, Dan Gagnon, Hannah Gadsby.
Mmm-hmm.
Tu penses qu'il y a un truc dans l'humour qui attire les gens comme ça ?
Imagine la pauvre Hannah Gadsby qui se retrouve au milieu de tous les autres teubés que t'as cités.
Tu penses qu'il y a un truc dans l'humour qui attire ces gens-là ?
Bah ouais, je pense qu'il y a
Ces gens-là, des gens comme ça.
...y a ce besoin de... Clairement, à un moment, on n'a pas été assez aimé et on a besoin de compenser avec la validation de centaines d'inconnus.
Mais ouais, puis je pense aussi ce besoin de se réapproprier des événements qui nous ont rendus tristes et d'en faire quelque chose de positif quoi.
C'est vraiment essayer de combler quelque chose.
OK, donc c'est vraiment combler un manque. C'est presque triste 'fin comme description, de me dire des gens qui vont pas bien quoi.
Ouais. Chacun des applaudissements m'enterre un peu.
Donc toi, tu te décrirais comme ça, quelqu'un qui va pas bien, à qui il manque quelque chose ?
Non, parce que maintenant, voilà, justement, le stand up et tout ce qu'il y a autour, ça m'a permis de, bah de trouver une certaine validation, d'avoir un peu plus confiance en moi, de
réfléchir aussi, l'écriture, le fait de devoir écrire des sketchs, des chroniques et tout sur des choses de ma vie ou de la façon dont je fonctionne, ça m'oblige en fait à
mieux les structurer et donc à mieux me comprendre et ça change beaucoup de choses en fait.
Mmm. Donc t'es épanouie aujourd'hui ?
Bah, en tout cas, plus qu'avant.
OK, cool. Et du coup, si tout va bien, qu'est-ce qui te fatigue dans la vie ? Qu'est-ce que t'aimes pas ?
Bah là, je t'avoue, en plein confinement, c'est pas le meilleur moment pour me poser la question. Parce que là...
Vas-y, crache ta haine.
Non, mais non, justement, je suis très zen hein.
OK.
...en tout cas aujourd'hui. Donc ben non, mais ce qui me fatigue, c'est moi en général. C'est de pas... Genre je sais que j'ai des choses qui fonctionnent mal et je continue de les faire, tu vois.
Genre je sais que j'ai tendance à accepter trop de choses et de gaver mon planning et de me dire : « C'est bon, t'inquiète.
Je fais un métier que j'aime, donc je vais pas être fatiguée. » C'est faux.
Mmm.
C'est faux. Tu peux pas faire deux chroniques par semaine, cinq spectacles, écrire des vidéos, faire des trucs. Tu peux pas.
À un moment, va chier en fait. Parce que genre à un moment, je bossais tellement que dans mes chroniques, j'avais absolument plus rien à raconter en fait.
Donc voilà, trouver... Je sais que je suis pas toujours la meilleure pour trouver des justes milieux entre les choses.
Donc voilà, y a ça qui m'a beaucoup énervée chez moi. Y a le fait que ouais, ces trucs de non-productivité, mais d'un côté, ce besoin de productivité qui est pas normal.
Genre, je suis toujours en mode je me déteste si j'avance pas sur des choses quoi, alors que putain, des fois, chill the fuck out.
Et voilà, c'est un peu ces trucs de toujours quitte ou double, toujours tout ou rien en fait. Et c'est pas toujours très sain.
Et tu penses que c'est intrinsèque à toi ? C'est qui tu es ? Tu pourras jamais être autrement ?
Bah, je sais que certaines choses s'améliorent, mais en tout cas, c'est toujours, c'est quelque chose que je vais toujours devoir garder à l'œil parce que sinon, ça revient très vite quoi.
Donc, tu veux dire que tu t'appelles Fanny Ruwet et nous écoutons Les Gens Qui Doutent ?
Bah oui. Toujours.
Ouais. Tu doutes de quoi à part ça ?
Mon nouveau... 'Fin mon nouveau truc. Un truc qui me tourne beaucoup en tête ces derniers mois, c'est : est-ce que je fais le bon métier ?
Est-ce que j'aime réellement ça ou est-ce que j'ai l'impression que je dois aimer ça parce que c'est incroyable ce qui m'arrive ?
Et je sais que tellement de gens
Tu vivrais mal le fait de renoncer à ça maintenant parce que tu te dirais : « C'est presque un crime. » Y a tellement de gens qui voudraient en être arrivés là.
C'est pas que je le vivrais mal, parce que ça, je me dirais : « Bah écoute, OK, si t'es heureuse en faisant d'autres choses, fais-le ».
Mais c'est juste que
j'arrive pas à savoir si je me mens à moi-même ou si c'est vrai, tu vois. Donc, je me dis : « Mais peut-être que j'aime ça uniquement parce que je vois bien que plein de gens autour de moi aimeraient jouer à Montreux, aller chez
chez France Inter, tourner dans des villes où j'ai jamais mis les pieds et que ce soit sold out quand même.
» C'est ouf. Surtout après genre un an et demi, c'est complètement ouf, ça n'a pas de sens. Et donc je suis obligée d'aimer ça, je suis obligée d'être contente, tu vois.
Et des fois, je me pose la question : est-ce que j'aime réellement ça ? Parce que c'est pas normal des fois de galérer et d'avoir pas envie d'écrire une chronique si c'est ce que je veux faire dans la vie.
Mais d'un côté, si, c'est normal parce que tu peux pas toujours avoir envie de travailler. 'Fin genre, tu vois, c'est toujours des questionnements comme ça où je sais pas exactement ce que je pense et ce que je crois penser en fait.
Tu penses que t'es quelqu'un qui évalue à quel point t'es bien dans la vie, à quel point t'es zen, heureuse, sur base de à quel point les gens t'envient, ont envie d'être là où t'en es ?
Mmm. Bah disons que c'est un truc que tu prends un peu en compte quand tu sais que t'as de la chance.
Tu te sens un peu mal quand tu te sens mal en fait, parce que tu te dis : « Putain, mais je devrais tellement être heureux là parce que plein de gens aimeraient ça ».
C'est un peu un truc qui fait culpabiliser, mais est-ce que je considère la jalousie comme une preuve ? Ouais, honnêtement, c'est une mauvaise chose, mais je pense que oui.
C'est récurrent ou c'est juste, en cherchant un peu, ça doit jouer un peu, ou c'est une grande force motrice ?
Non, c'est pas une grande force motrice. Je me dis pas genre j'ai envie qu'il m'arrive ça.
Qu'est-ce que je vais faire aujourd'hui ?
Rendre les gens jaloux. C'est ce qui me fait vivre.
Non, c'est pas une force motrice, mais disons que je pense que c'est un peu un truc en fond comme ça, un truc un peu viscéral, dégueulasse qui colle au fond des poumons comme ça. Ouais.
OK. Et du coup, je reviens là-dessus, mais les gens que t'aimes pas ?
Tous.
OK.
Un truc qui m'agace : les gens qui sont pas bienveillants.
OK. Tu penses à qui ? Tu penses à quoi ?
Je pense à rien en particulier, mais par exemple, un truc qui m'horripile, c'est le mensonge. Je ne comprends pas.
J'ai des problèmes avec ça, mais c'est ouf. L'autre jour, on regardait avec deux amis Ghostbusters et le personnage de Bill Murray est dégueulasse.
Au début, il se comporte mal, il ment et tout et on a dû arrêter le film.
Sérieux ?
Ouais, je déteste.
Mais nan, c'est un personnage de fiction. C'est
Ouais, mais
C'est de base un mensonge, ça n'est pas vraiment arrivé.
Oui. Quoi ? Mais non, mais genre, je regarde pas un film pour genre chiller, pour voir des gens qui font un truc que j'aime pas.
'Fin... Non, j'ai vraiment un truc avec le mensonge. Mais je comprends pas en fait, parce que tout peut être dit, tout peut être entendu.
Il suffit d'être honnête et si t'expliques par A plus B comment ça se passe, ben c'est OK. Et je ne comprends pas.
Donc voilà, ça m'horripile. Même des trucs à la con hein.
Ouais, mais tu sais qu'un jour, tu m'as conseillé de mentir.
Ah ouais ? C'était pour quoi ?
J'avais un enregistrement qui s'était mal passé avec quelqu'un. Et tu m'as dit : « Bah dis-lui que t'as un problème avec le son ».
Ah ouais. Bah moi, j'aurais pas été capable de faire ça, mais
Ah oui, c'est ça. Tu suggères aux autres de le faire, mais toi, tu pourrais pas.
Ouais.
Et du coup, est-ce qu'il t'arrive de, comme t'as un problème viscéral avec le mensonge, de genre éviter complètement de répondre, de fuir les gens, ouais.
Ça, c'est comme ça que je survis hein, l'omission et le fait de répondre au second degré, comme ça les gens pensent que c'est pour rire.
Tu fais jamais semblant de rigoler ? Tu fais jamais semblant d'être complaisante ?
Si, je pense.
Mais c'est du mensonge.
Ouais... Alors oui, mais non, en fait. 'Fin, moi, l'exemple que j'ai en tête, c'est si un jeune humoriste vient me dire : « Putain, j'ai pensé à ça, machin », et je vais faire : « OK ».
Et tu vois, c'est juste pour être agréable, mais jamais je vais lui dire : « J'ai adoré ce que t'as fait » si c'est pas le cas, tu vois.
C'est pour ça que j'évite de... Je demande jamais l'avis des gens sur ce que je fais. Genre, je leur demande jamais frontalement leur avis parce que je sais que moi, je déteste quand on me le demande, parce que si c'est bien, je vais le dire moi-même.
Et je sais que si on me le demande, je vais pas savoir dire que c'est bien si je le pense pas. C'est toujours très gênant, genre sur des plateaux en interview et tout, quand on te demande : « Oh, qu'est-ce que vous pensez de ça ?
» Et moi, je suis là : « Eh ben visuellement, c'est pas mal hein ».
Mais c'est un mensonge par omission, ça. Est-ce que t'es pas justement du genre en interview à répondre frontalement à des trucs où normalement, il serait attendu que tu fasses du bullshit ?
Bah, ça dépend. Des fois, j'ai tendance à être un peu trop franche parce que des choses me choquent pas, mais apparemment, les gens, ça les choque. Mais
Tu penses à quoi quand tu dis ça ?
Bah par exemple, c'était une interview avec Léa, je pense. Il m'avait demandé pourquoi j'avais commencé le stand-up et j'avais dit : « Bah parce que je trouvais plein de gens nuls et je voulais voir si j'étais capable de faire mieux ».
Et tu répondais ça au premier degré ou à
Ah, c'est totalement du premier degré. Et c'est vrai qu'après, quand ma prod a relu ça, ils m'ont dit : « Ouais, peut-être, on va
Légèrement arrogant.
Mais non, ils m'ont dit : « Tu dois pas mentir, dis ce que tu penses, mais peut-être pas tourner comme ça quoi. » Peut-être pas utiliser le mot nul.
Mais voilà, maintenant, j'essaie quand même toujours de rester agréable, mais c'est juste que je vais soigner... Faire de mon mieux, mais sans mentir quoi.
Ouais, donc par omission, en faisant des espèces de pirouettes pour éviter de répondre directement.
C'est ça.
Ouais, OK.
On va essayer de changer de sujet en fourbe pour ne pas avoir à donner mon avis sur des choses que j'aime pas.
Et d'où ça te vient, à ton avis, cette détestation du mensonge ?
Je pense que ça vient d'une peur absolue que les gens me mentent.
Parce que si tu peux pas faire confiance à quelqu'un, mais la vie n'a pas d'intérêt en fait, parce qu'il y a tellement de choses à remettre en question et ça doit être terrorisant.
Mmmh. Et pourtant, si on part du principe que le mensonge, il est partout dans le monde et que
des espèces de mensonges, tu sais, little white lies, des petits mensonges qui font pas de mal pour éviter de heurter la personne, etc., c'est
ça nous entoure partout, 'fin c'est constant.
Mmmh.
Bah, t'as beaucoup de gens qui semblent bien le vivre, pas se plaindre, pas dire en interview qu'ils détestent les gens qui mentent.
T'es un peu une exception.
Mais tant mieux pour eux.
Ouais. Oui, non, mais bien sûr, mais je dis... 'Fin, tu dis de manière, tu sais, assez universelle : « C'est horrible le fait de
Ah non, mais pour moi
...tout le temps se douter » et tout.
Pour moi, ça me terroriserait. C'est ça que les gens que j'ai autour de moi, je sais que c'est des gens qui sont capables de me dire : « Ce que tu viens de faire, c'est mauvais ».
Et des fois, tu le sens passer hein, t'as envie de crever un peu, mais je sais que c'est pas des gens qui vont me dire ce que j'ai envie qu'ils me disent.
Et ça, c'est tellement précieux quoi. J'ai vraiment mon petit squad autour de moi où je sais que je peux leur faire confiance sur le fait qu'ils me mentiront pas.
Et comment est-ce que tu sais ça ? Y a toujours le doute.
Mmmh oui et non parce que je suis le genre de personne à qui on peut dire à peu près n'importe quoi. Et je me choque pas vite et j'ai pas de souci à admettre
qu'il y ait des réactions qui soient normales, naturelles, même si elles sont pas chouettes en fait.
Parce que 'fin j'sais pas, y a des comportements
Comme si t'es sur scène et que quelqu'un vient chez toi et te dit : « T'es vraiment, c'est vraiment de la merde, je trouvais ça nul. »
Quand je suis sur scène ?
Non, non, tu descends de scène. C'est fini. Tu prends ton verre au King, t'es dans ton coin avec ton staff.
Et puis y a quelqu'un qui vient et qui te fait un commentaire super désagréable.
Si c'est... Ça dépend, si c'est désagréable dans la forme, je trouve pas ça correct parce que restons courtois, mais si c'est dans le fond, si quelqu'un me dit : « Voilà, j'ai pas aimé pour telle raison, telle raison, telle raison ».
Déjà, y a l'aspect c'est subjectif et donc peut-être que juste t'as pas accroché parce que c'est pas ton genre d'humour machin.
Ou si tu peux me prouver par A plus B que en effet, y a des choses qui étaient mal construites, qui étaient mal amenées, j'ai oublié de refermer des parenthèses et tout ça, je peux totalement l'entendre.
C'est juste de manière générale en fait.
T'es pas quelqu'un de susceptible, t'es pas quelqu'un de susceptible où dès qu'on va t'attaquer, tu vas avoir envie de mourir ?
Mmmh ça dépend. Bah déjà, je commence un peu à m'habituer avec internet.
Mhm. Ouais.
Mais puis en fait non, ça va, ça va me rendre un peu mal, mais dans le sens, je vais me dire : « Putain, sur certains points, si je sais qu'il a raison, je vais me dire : « Putain, les gens se rendent compte ».
Et ça va me casser les couilles et donc je vais travailler plus fort. Donc ça va en fait.
Mmmh.
Mais peut-être que je me mens moi-même hein et que en fait, je vais chialer en PLS, tu vois.
Ouais. Dans 30 ans en thérapie. Tu parlais d'Internet. Je me souviens qu'un jour, tu m'avais expliqué que de manière générale, on t'emmerdait pas.
Mmmh.
Que t'étais-- y avait pas des gros cons misogynes qui faisaient des commentaires sexistes à la con. Inversement, y a d'autres gens qui doivent, qui se plaignent beaucoup de ça.
Comment est-ce que t'expliques que toi, tu sois relativement épargnée par ça ?
Bah, je pense qu'y a plusieurs choses qui jouent. Le fait que les gens ne me sexualisent pas parce que je suis pas-- 'fin, j'ai l'air d'avoir 12 ans.
Et puis je suis pas spécialement cute, donc ça ne-- y a pas ce truc de-- mais non, mais objectivement, c'est vrai, tu vois.
Et du coup, les gens ne ramènent pas ça directement au physique parce qu'ils s'en battent les couilles en fait.
Et donc y a un peu cet aspect-là. Y a le fait aussi que je ne cherche pas spécialement à provoquer de-- j'ai très rarement des prises d'opinion dans mes chroniques.
J'évite ça le plus possible parce que je veux pas avoir
potentiellement tort dans ce que je raconte. C'est pour ça que tout ce que je raconte quasiment n'est que des histoires de ma vie, parce que je sais qu'on ne peut pas me contredire, parce que c'est vrai, parce que voilà, c'est pas
un truc
hypothèse, antithèse, machin, c'est vraiment personnel et je veux pas qu'on puisse me contredire en fait.
Et du coup, bah ça fait assez peu réagir les gens en mal parce que personne ne va dire : « Oh non, tu as tort, il t'est pas arrivé ça ».
Et donc, bah y a moins de haine en fait provoquée à mon égard.
OK. Et qu'est-ce tu penses de ce que dit Dan quand il dit que tu comprends que t'as tort ? Bah c'est, oui, c'est une forme d'apaisement.
Tu comprends, t'as eu tort et tu t'apaises. Et c'est-- on dirait que t'as très peur d'avoir tort.
Ouais. Ouais, ouais, ouais, parce que-
Bah pourquoi ? C'est comme ça qu'on apprend ?
Oui, mais j'ai besoin de savoir qu'à un moment, le travail est fini en fait. C'est ce qu'on disait tantôt avec mes micro deadlines.
J'ai besoin de savoir qu'y a de la lumière au bout du tunnel. Et avec les opinions, y en a pas. Parce que tu dois tout le temps remettre tout en question.
Et en général, sur la plupart des sujets, je ne ressens pas assez d'intérêt. J'ai pas assez de connaissances du coup pour me permettre d'avoir des opinions.
Et parce que y a juste pas grand-chose qui m'intéresse concrètement. Et du coup, par exemple, la politique, j'ai jamais dit le moindre truc en politique, dans mes chroniques ou quoi que ce soit, parce que je m'en bats les couilles, en fait.
Ouais, mais quand tu parles de pas avoir d'opinion, que ce soit politique ou autre chose, c'est juste ne pas les formuler, ne pas en parler en public parce que t'as pas envie d'avoir tort et qu'on voit que t'as tort ?
Ou bien même de manière générale, t'es pas quelqu'un qui a des opinions, tu crois que c'est ça ?
Je suis pas quelqu'un qui a des opinions très tranchées en général parce que je pense que c'est ce que-- en fait, y a tellement de choses à prendre en considération.
Y a tellement de nuances à apporter à tous les débats que j'ai pas cette patience et cette envie en fait. Et
Ouais, non y a, non y a trop de choses à connaître, y a trop de choses à apprendre pour avoir des opinions qui valent la peine d'être partagées.
Et donc-- ou même pour s'en faire en fait. Et donc en général, j'ai pas le courage de me lancer là-dedans.
C'est peut-être aussi quelque chose qu'on peut dire quand on est dans une position où on t'emmerde pas trop et où, tu vois, si t'étais quelqu'un de super opprimé, super oppressé, t'aurais peut-être un peu plus envie de lever le poing.
Totalement. Ah totalement, j'ai vraiment une position privilégiée, totalement. Et y a évidemment des sujets sur lesquels j'ai des opinions et tout, mais-- si quelqu'un--
ouais, c'est assez, mais f-- non, non, t'as raison, si je-- ben opprimez-moi, opprimez-moi sur, venez m'insulter, mettez-moi des bâtons dans les roues.
Beh, mais justement, justement, t'as fait une chronique y a pas longtemps sur France Inter où tu parlais
du fait que on te comparait tout le temps aux autres humoristes femmes, on te réduisait à ça, on te : « Oui, on ne sait pas aussi bien que Marina Rollman et t'as la même intonation et t'as la même voix.
» Y avait une forme d'opinion pour le coup, tu exprimais quelque chose.
Oui, là c'est bon, c'est la première fois que je donnais une opinion dans une chronique.
Parce qu'on t'emmerdait, parce qu'on t'emprimait en te comparant-
C'est ça
...à Marina Rollman. Ouais.
Beh oui, et puis surtout de manière générale, les femmes dans les milieux artistiques sont toujours comparées entre elles, même si leur travail n'a rien à voir.
Donc ouais, c'est ça qui me cassait les couilles. Et oui, c'est-- pour une fois que c'était un truc que je vivais moi-même, bah là, j'en ai parlé quoi.
Donc ça montre à quel point ma vie est dure. Mais oui, en effet, et là, la vidéo, j'pense que c'est-- elle a fait genre quatre ou cinq fois plus de vues que mes autres chroniques.
Y a eu, j'sais pas, genre 100 fois plus de commentaires. Oui, là, ça a fait réagir. Et en effet, je me suis un peu pris plein de commentaires positifs et plein de très très négatifs.
Donc ouais, c'est un peu le prix à payer quand t'as des opinions et voilà.
Mh. Et tu penses qu'y a aucune légitimité, aucune véracité dans la comparaison avec Marina Rollman ?
Oh si, avec Marina, si.
C'est qui les autres avec lesquels on te comparait ?
Blanche Gardin.
Ah oui, bien sûr.
Et des fois, on m'a sorti des trucs qui n'avaient aucun sens.
Bah Florence Mendez aussi, on te confond des fois.
Oui, oui, ouais, beaucoup. Mais ah oui, si, avec Marina, je comprends, tu vois, mais faut pas déconner non plus, genre...
Mais le truc, c'est-- je peux à la limite comprendre qu'on fasse des : « Ah oui, la voix ressemble un peu » ou je sais pas quoi, de loin.
Parce que moi, y a des podcasts que j'écoute depuis des années et au début, j'arrivais pas à différencier les voix entre les personnes.
Et aujourd'hui, ça me paraît évident, mais je comprends qu'on puisse se dire ça, mais je trouve ça bizarre que on se dise : « Je vais en faire un reproche et je vais dire : "T'es nul parce que ça."
» Et 'fin, on se dit : « Mais que-- what, what's the point ? Pourquoi est-ce que tu ouvres ta bouche pour dire ça ? »
Ouais, mais ça, j'ai arrêté de me poser la question de pourquoi les gens qui voient du contenu gratuitement sur Internet commencent à insulter les gens parce que ça leur plaît pas.
Tu fais : « Mais putain, dude, what the fuck ? » Ça n'a pas de sens. Mais non, du coup, j'ai arrêté de-- ouais, tout ce qui est commentaires sur Internet, j'ai arrêté de lire.
Ouais, mais t'y arrives ?
Bah honnêtement, ouais, parce que, bah d'un côté, y en a beaucoup. J'ai quand même pas mal de trucs qui tournent en même temps et du coup, j'ai pas le temps de tout lire.
Et puis j'ai rien de bien à y gagner en fait, parce que soit ça va être positif et ça va être : « Putain, c'est trop bien » et tout, et ça va me complaire dans-- je vais un peu avoir envie de me reposer sur mes lauriers ou alors ça va-
Dans ton addiction à la dopamine.
Ouais, mais non c'est-- ou alors, je vais avoir envie de crever. Donc voilà, y a rien de bien à y gagner.
Ah. Ouais, est-ce que c'est possible que dans 10 ans, tu sois plus du tout active là-dedans ? Que t'aies changé d'avis ?
Je suis même pas sûre que je ferai un deuxième spectacle. C'est-
Ah ouais ? À ce point-là ?
Oui, parce que je sais pas en fait. Peut-être que dans deux ans, voilà, j'aurai tourné celui-là et je me dirai : « Bah, c'était bien hein, mais c'est tout.
» C'est, je sais pas en fait. Je pense que j'aurai toujours envie d'écrire des choses.
Bah pour les autres alors, peut-être.
Mais ouais, soit pour les autres, soit sur un support différent ou je sais pas trop. Honnêtement, je sais pas trop.
En fait, ma vie n'a tellement aucun sens en bien pour l'instant que je sais même plus me projeter. Genre là, j'ai pris un bail d'un an, tu vois, parce qu'on sait jamais.
J'en ai aucune idée.
Ça fait un an et demi, deux ans que je te vois sur scène faire du stand-up. Tu dis que tu vas encore faire ce spectacle pendant encore deux ans ?
Bah là, le spectacle-
Ça te lasse pas ?
...depuis moins d'un an. Bah en fait, c'est surtout qu'il faut en fait, parce que c'est un premier spectacle et que le-- et encore, c'est court pour un premier spectacle.
Logiquement, ça se joue genre cinq ans.
Parce que faut le temps que les gens te voient, faut le temps que tu te fasses connaître avec, puis que tu joues dans
des 100 places à Paris un soir semaine, puis deux soirs semaine, puis que tu passes dans un trois, 300 places et puis trois soirs semaine dans un 300 places.
Et puis tu fais des grosses salles, tu fais une tournée. 'Fin, y a plein de steps comme ça préconçus par lesquels tu dois passer.
Donc c'est déjà court en fait. Là, je vais le jouer deux ans et demi au total. Et donc ouais, ça va être un peu challengeant d'essayer de pas me faire chier, je pense.
Mais ouais, je sais pas, je vais trouver des solutions. Peut-être qu'à un moment, je commencerai à interagir un peu plus avec le public pour qu'il y ait quelque chose de nouveau à chaque show.
Peut-être que je vais rajouter des menottes aussi.
Tu dis beaucoup que t'es nulle en improvisation et en interaction avec le public.
Ouais.
C'est quelque chose que t'as envie d'améliorer ? Parce que tu dis t'as envie de le faire plus.
Non.
Est-ce que c'est pas ton pire cauchemar ?
Bah en fait, j'aime pas parce que souvent, ça va mener à des choses qui n'ont pas trop d'intérêt. Et je pense que y a déjà assez de choses dans le monde qui n'ont pas d'intérêt.
Et donc j'ai pas envie de rajouter quatre minutes de bullshit dans mon spectacle à demander : « Ah bah putain, ta chemise, elle est moche », machin.
Et tu fais : « Putain, mais niquez tous bien vos mères en fait ». Les gens sont pas venus pour ça et moi, j'ai pas envie de faire ça.
Donc non. Maintenant, des fois, y a des choses qui se passent qui sont très comiques. Genre, j'ai joué à Paris en février genre.
Et c'était une petite salle de 55 personnes, c'était au Barbès. Et parmi ces 55 personnes, y a genre un groupe de 30 étudiants qui sont venus avec l'école à mon spectacle.
Ils avaient quel âge ?
Bah 17, genre.
Ah OK.
Et genre, c'est eux qui avaient choisi. Et j'étais là : « Mais qui a autorisé ça ? » Allez, moi à 17 ans, j'aurais pas voulu voir mes profs rigoler sur des blagues de sperme, putain.
Donc voilà, y a tout ce truc-là. Et puis vu que je parle de quand j'avais leur âge et tout, ben c'était assez marrant.
Et donc là, y a eu pas mal d'interactions qui étaient dues au fait que y avait fucking 30, 35 jeunes dans ma salle quoi.
Et donc c'est, ouais, des choses comme ça qui se passent qui sont assez marrantes. Ou ouais, des fois des événements un peu particuliers ou des choses qui sont dues au contexte.
Il m'est arrivé un truc ce jour-là, ben je peux en parler au début et faire quelques running gags dessus et donc ça change un peu.
Mais ouais, ça dépend, mais j'aime pas partir du principe que je vais parler au public d'office quoi.
Mais pourtant, c'est ce que tu disais tout à l'heure, que c'était peut-être quelque chose que tu voulais faire davantage.
Ben c'est peut-être que-- je sais pas, parce que peut-être qu'en fait, je vais me rendre compte que c'est trop bien. Je sais que Thomas Wiesel,
Lucas Cosco et tout, au début, ils détestaient ça et maintenant, ils aiment bien parce que c'est un peu un jeu aussi, un challenge
d'arriver à improviser et d'essayer d'en tirer quelque chose d'intéressant, tu vois.
C'est un challenge, mais pour l'instant, j'ai pas trop envie de le relever.
Y a pas un truc qui t'est arrivé un jour, une histoire sur scène ?
Ben non, moi, tout est très lisse en fait. J'ai jamais eu de trucs énormes qui se sont passés ou des choses dans des conditions vraiment déplorables.
Justement, t'as jamais eu un heckler, quelqu'un qui te vannait depuis le public et t'étais un peu obligée de lui répondre parce que c'est attendu de toi ?
Non. En fait, je pense que j'ai ce truc, cette face un peu désagréable qui fait que les gens ont pas envie de me parler comme ça.
Donc j'ai cette chance. Par contre, une fois à Lille début janvier, je jouais à Lille et y a un mec qui est sorti de la salle pendant le spectacle parce qu'il a été vexé par une vanne.
Et c'est la première fois que ça m'est arrivé. Mais je m'en suis pas rendue compte en fait.
C'est seulement après-
Mais en l'apprenant, t'étais mal à l'aise ?
Oui, en fait. Parce que ça me rend triste que quelqu'un ait pu être peiné pendant mon spectacle au point de quitter la salle.
C'était quoi la vanne ?
Alors, cette situation est affreuse hein, je te préviens. Du coup, je sais pas si je dois-- en fait, y a un potentiel comique qui est fou, mais c'est tragique.
En fait, j'ai une blague-
C'est parfait
...qui-- ah non, mais c'est affreux. J'ai une blague dans le spectacle qui est très-
Je suis très excité, Fanny, tu peux pas savoir.
Chut ! J'ai donc une blague qui est une des toutes premières. C'est dans les sept premières minutes du show. C'est vraiment les toutes premières blagues que j'ai écrites, donc elles sont pas ouf.
Et clairement, s'y en a qui doivent sauter, c'est celles-là. Mais j'ai un truc où je fais une comparaison.
'Fin, je dis : « Y a des fois, tu fais des choses qui partent d'une bonne intention, mais ce n'est pas une bonne idée. C'est comme dire à quelqu'un : "Ah, t'as maigri" et il a le sida.
» C'est une bête comparaison qui-
C'est un peu trash quoi, c'est un peu violent
C'est un peu gratuit. C'est-- honnêtement, j'en suis pas fière, mais d'un côté, je suis pas en train de me foutre de la gueule des gens qui sont séropositifs.
Et la blague est sur l'intention et sur la maladresse. Euh-
Ouais, le moment de gêne après où tu te rends compte que en fait-
Voilà, c'est ça
...j'ai fait une gaffe.
Et il se trouve que ce monsieur est séropositif et l'avait appris peu avant la date.
OK.
Et, wait for it. En fait, ses copains lui avaient offert la place pour le cheer up. Et-- c'est affreux, putain. C'est affreux.
Ouais, t'as l'air de mal le vivre. Enfin, c'est pas de ta faute.
Non, c'est pas de ma faute, tu vois. Surtout que le mec, il est sorti, il était-- en fait, le truc, c'est qu'il avait bu avant de venir.
Et du coup, il a un peu surréagi et tout. Donc il est sorti apparemment assez énervé à dire que c'était scandaleux, qu'on pouvait pas rire de ça et tout ça.
Et puis donc moi, je suis sortie de scène, on m'a expliqué ça et tout. Et juste en rentrant à l'hôtel, j'ai vu que j'avais un message de ce gars-là sur Facebook.
Wow.
Et message qui était en fait pas du tout agressif, qui était en mode : « Voilà, je suis sorti parce que j'ai été peiné par votre blague, parce que je trouve qu'on peut rire de tout » et tout ça, machin.
« C'est bien normal, ça détend, ça dédramatise et tout, mais pas de ça. » Et j'étais là : « Mais tu te contredis en fait. »
Ouais.
« Et ça n'a pas de sens. » Et du coup, je lui ai répondu assez longuement. Déjà, j'ai réexpliqué
toute la blague vraiment en, en, en mettant en plusieurs morceaux vraiment pour mettre bien en avant le fait que c'était pas du tout quelque chose d'agressif envers
envers l'aspect tragique du truc.
Et puis j'ai expliqué en quoi je trouvais qu'on pouvait en effet faire des blagues sur tout et machin et que son message était en fait assez contradictoire et que voilà, mais...
C'est comme-- y a un comic strip comme ça avec deux personnes qui sont à table dans la première case et l'une qui dit à l'autre : « Ah, mais je trouve votre humour formidable, subtil, fin, très intelligent.
» Puis la deuxième case, c'est le personnage se lève et on voit qu'il a un bermuda et il dit : « Mais par contre, vos blagues sur les gens qui portent des bermudas sont vraiment grossières et maladroites. »
Ouais, c'est ça.
Et c'est un peu ça, quoi, ce que tu me dis.
C'est ça, c'est vraiment : tu peux rire de tout sauf quand ça me touche personnellement. Et ça, bah non, niquez-vous en fait.
En même temps, je comprends que ce soit dur dans cette situation, hein.
Ah mais totalement, totalement. Et je suis vraiment, ça m'a beaucoup peiné. Et voilà, et je lui ai dit : « Revenez voir le spectacle quand vous voulez » et tout, « et on se voit après, on en discute » et tout.
Voilà.
Tu voulais qu'il repaye sa place ?
Non, non, je lui ai dit : « Je vous invite, venez avec qui vous voulez. »
Ah, nul.
Ouais, je sais, j'aurais dû pousser un peu. Mais voilà, non, c'est ce truc : en fait, tu peux pas avoir un double discours.
Soit tu trouves qu'on peut pas rire de tout et c'est ton point de vue et voilà. Soit commence pas à casser les couilles avec ta susceptibilité si
toi, tu peux taper sur les autres, mais que t'es pas d'accord de te faire taper dessus en retour, quoi.
Ouais. Et mais du coup, je sens quand même un petit peu de regret dans ta voix. Je me trompe peut-être un petit peu ?
Ouais, ouais, parce que, de nouveau, l'objectif, c'est de passer un bon moment, tu vois. Et c'est vrai que cette vanne, elle est pas ouf, hein.
Si c'était une vanne dont j'étais fière, ce serait mieux passé. Mais là, je me suis dit : « Putain, j'ai vexé quelqu'un pour ça, ça vaut pas la peine. »
Mais c'était une de tes toutes premières vannes, je pense que ça…
Ouais, je pense qu'elle était dans…
Elle date de tout début.
…dans le tout premier cinq minutes que j'ai écrit.
Ouais.
Et où probablement qu'elle va sauter.
Est-ce que c'est lié à ça ?
Pas directement, mais ça m'a fait réaliser à quel point j'assumais vraiment moins ce que j'avais écrit tout au début.
Mmh.
Parce que c'est pas très bon, c'est un peu facile, c'est un peu… y a des portes ouvertes, bah tiens, je vais y aller, quoi.
Et quand tu regardes le spectacle d'humoristes bien établis et que tu vois des vannes un peu à charge, je dirais des vannes,
où plutôt que de rire avec les gens, on se fout de leur gueule de manière un peu violente.
Mmh-mmh.
Ça te pose pas de problème, c'est juste…
Ah, ça me dégoûte un peu en fait.
…le fait que la vanne soit trop facile ?
Ouais, c'est trop facile.
Non, attends, là y a deux choses. Est-ce qu'on se moque de quelqu'un et y a une forme de violence, ou bien est-ce que c'est juste une vanne facile ?
Et alors, enfin, c'est nul de faire une vanne trop facile. C'est deux choses différentes. Qu'est-ce qui te dérange ?
Ben un peu les deux en fait. En fait, ça dépend comment tu fais le truc, parce que si tu te moques de quelqu'un vraiment, en fait j'aime pas ça, tu vois, je trouve pas ça cool.
C'est comme faire des blagues sur la pédophilie, tu vois, tu fais : « Mais non, en fait, c'est pas…
» À moins que t'aies un truc vraiment bien construit, un angle particulier et tout, mais juste faire une blague, trouver un jeu de mots avec Marc Dutroux parce que juste, tu l'as trouvé.
Mais non, en fait, ça n'a aucun intérêt et je trouve que l'humour, il doit y avoir une recherche derrière, ça doit être travaillé.
Tu peux pas juste trouver que ton jeu de mots est génial juste parce que tu l'as trouvé. Donc y a…
Et encore une fois, là, tu parles de la qualité du travail, tu dis : « Bah c'est trop facile, ça n'a aucun intérêt. »
Ouais.
Mais l'autre aspect, qui est de blesser les gens qui sont séropositifs, qui sont victimes de pédophilie, qui sont ceci, qui sont cela, est-ce que c'est un frein pour toi ou est-ce que ça…
Ben c'est pas quelque chose que j'ai envie de faire, mais…
Mais tu peux en rire quand tu vois les spectacles des autres ?
En fait, si je suis surprise, je vais avoir un rire de surprise.
Ouais, ouais, OK.
Des trucs genre…
C'est le principe généralement.
Oui, c'est ça.
Tu dis un truc super trash, super dark et ça te surprend et voilà, ouais.
Mais à part ça, je suis pas trop fan de… genre l'humour dans les humoristes français, y a souvent ça en fait, ils se foutent des trucs un peu sexistes, un peu racistes et tout et tu fais : « Mais putain, les gars, non en fait.
» Non seulement c'est pas original, mais en plus tu dis vraiment des choses qui sont pas cool. Et moi, c'est ça que j'aime dans les spectacles des humoristes que j'aime, c'est le mélange d'intelligence et de,
et de travail comique.
Genre Hannah Gadsby, c'est le cas.
Ouais, ouais. Là, tu formules une opinion pour le coup. T'as une pensée sur un sujet, tu juges les gens qui ne partagent pas ton avis et tu l'exprimes en public.
C'est exactement ce que tu disais que tu voulais pas faire.
Oui, mais en fait, là, j'ai pas de point à prouver, tu vois, c'est juste mon opinion et je vais pas…
j'ai rien à défendre, tu vois, c'est ma façon de voir les choses et je vais pas commencer… si quelqu'un me dit : « Non, t'as tort », je vais dire : « Ah OK, bah tu trouves qu'on n'est pas d'accord. Allez, bye. »
C'est ça.
J'ai rien à gagner dans des débats en fait. Dan dit souvent : « Je préfère avoir la paix qu'avoir raison » et c'est totalement ça.
Maintenant, y a des choses qui m'ont fait rire aussi avec lesquelles j'étais pas du tout d'accord. Genre dans le dernier Blanche Gardin,
elle a un sketch où elle parle des meufs qui sont habillées court et qui doivent pas trop s'étonner de se prendre des commentaires et tout.
Et elle a tout un discours comme ça avec lequel j'étais pas du tout d'accord, mais qui était tellement bien torché que je rigolais quand même, tu vois.
Donc je peux trouver la forme qualitative et trouver que c'est un bon spectacle, mais sans être d'accord avec les propos.
Y a d'autres humoristes comme ça ? Je pense par exemple aux humoristes anglo-saxons américains
où tu te fais cette réflexion-là, des gens super talentueux, mais quand tu les écoutes, t'as un peu envie de vomir au fond de ta bouche.
Je pense que j'avais ressenti ça au show de Bill Burr, mais…
Ouais, c'est à lui que je pensais.
Ouais, mais en fait, je me rappelle plus assez bien. Mais en effet, mais je pense que c'est ce qu'il cherche aussi.
Ouais, ouais, complètement.
Donc voilà. Mais en fait, à partir du moment où tu sais qu'il frise avec ça en permanence, tu te dis : « Bah oui, bah c'est le jeu » et voilà.
Maintenant, je pense qu'il est totalement OK d'exprimer des choses qui sont abominables si c'est pour dénoncer en fait le propos, tu vois ?
Si tu dis : « Oh là là ! Insérer ici une phrase raciste que je ne vais pas dire parce qu'on sait jamais que tu coupes ça au montage et que tu le mettes en intro. »
Mais ça peut être pour dénoncer le truc, tu vois. Et tu peux avoir un double discours comme ça. Maintenant, c'est vrai que des fois y a des gens… genre Guiz avait un,
un sketch dans son premier spectacle où il disait qu'il avait ploté une meuf qui lui avait dit : « Non, non, arrête » et tout, mais que c'était dans son intérêt qu'il avait fait, tu vois, c'était pour elle.
Et tu vois, y a tout un truc comme ça où c'est du second degré et que oui, t'as besoin d'avoir du second degré pour comprendre que la personne qui te parle n'est pas abominable.
Mais voilà, je pense que c'est aux gens aussi d'avoir un minimum de bon sens et de lecture du truc, quoi.
Fanny, on arrive tout doucement au bout des 70 minutes.
Enfin !
Qu'est-ce que t'as lu dernièrement comme truc qui t'a bien plu ?
Qu'est-ce que j'ai lu dernièrement ? Là…
Qui a changé ta vie.
Qui a changé ma vie ? Oh putain, ça non. Non mais…
Bah par exemple, qu'est-ce que t'as pensé du bouquin de Chris Gethard ?
Y avait beaucoup de choses qui étaient pas nécessaires, mais y a quelques petits éléments sur le fait d'être un weirdo et de…
Mmh.
…de rater, de réessayer, de rater encore, de se détester pendant un petit temps et puis de réessayer quand même qui m'ont marquée et que j'ai fluorées, je pense. Donc
voilà, c'est un peu comme dans tous les bouquins autobiographiques
comme ça. C'est genre y a des phrases qui vont te marquer, que tu vas noter quelque part et qui vont de temps en temps te faire voir les choses différemment, mais tout n'est pas à prendre, quoi.
Mmh. Ouais, c'était vraiment au centre de son show quand il faisait le Chris Gethard Show. C'était quoi ?
Y a combien de temps ? Presque 10 ans maintenant.
Mais non, sérieux ?
Sur le Manhattan Neighborhood Network, le truc… t'sais y a une espèce de station de télé qui diffuse gratuitement à Manhattan et c'est un genre de service public.
Mmh-mmh.
Et tu peux aller te pointer là-bas et dire : « Bah voilà, moi, j'ai envie de faire une émission. » Et donc c'est plein de gens amateurs, ça vaut pas grand-chose.
Et lui, donc il était à UCB, le Upright Citizens Brigade, donc le truc de la méga, méga institution d'impro aux États-Unis.
Et il avait son show en live, pas à la télé, mais en live, sur scène, là-bas pendant des années.
Mmh-mmh.
Et puis on lui a proposé d'en faire une espèce d'émission de télé. Et c'était la meilleure télé que j'ai vue depuis… c'était incroyable.
Ah oui, les trucs où ils faisaient n'importe quoi comme défi et tout.
Ouais, c'est ça, ouais. Genre il… bon, ça, c'est un exemple un peu absurde, mais il ramenait un genre de boxeur thaïlandais.
Ouais.
Et il lui demandait de lui casser la jambe.
Ça fait un peu Jackass, mais non, mais genre t'avais une espèce de groupe punk qui faisait la musique comme souvent dans les late shows aux États-Unis.
Mmh-mmh.
Et donc t'avais cette musique d'entraînement au début de l'émission. Et puis ils avaient des jingles pour chaque personnage, chaque section de l'émission.
Et c'était super fun. Et t'avais un gars qui était tout le temps en maillot, qui s'appelait le Human Fish et qui était moitié poisson, moitié humain.
Et on lui posait des questions à travers l'émission. C'était très très bizarre et c'était très très drôle. Et c'est des souvenirs formidables que j'ai, mais non, c'est fini, ça n'existe plus.
Sacré truc.
Mais non, t'avais genre… mais en plus le truc, oui, le truc, c'est que t'avais genre des méga stars de l'humour américain.
T'avais John Mulaney, par exemple, qui venait et il était là, quoi. Et c'était ce truc super amateur à Manhattan avec des caméras toutes pourries, un public, 'fin un décor qui vaut trois fois rien et…
Mmh.
Et c'était vraiment trop bien. Ça me manque trop. Voilà, ça, c'est pour la parenthèse. Mais du coup, qu'est-ce que t'as lu comme truc que t'as beaucoup aimé ?
Si c'était pas le cas de celui-là.
Bah là, pour l'instant, je suis en train de lire Nicolas Mathieu, Leurs enfants après eux, qui a gagné le Goncourt y a deux ans, je pense, que Myriam m'avait conseillé et que tout le monde m'a conseillé depuis.
Myriam, celle qui n'a pas eu le Goncourt, du coup.
Oui, absolument. Une des nombreuses personnes qui n'ont pas eu le Goncourt. Donc voilà, c'est pas mal. Mais non, je t'avoue, pour l'instant, y a pas grand-chose qui m'a vraiment marquée.
Mais en même temps, je lis vraiment pas beaucoup, hein. J'ai acheté plein de trucs et j'en lis…
Ouais, c'est vrai que t'as un trouble de l'attention, j'avais oublié.
Ouais, c'est ça. Donc là, j'ai ça plus L'anatomie du scénario de John Truddy, Truby, pardon. Et donc voilà, j'avance là-dessus, je fluore.
D'autres choses à recommander ?
La série The Morning Show sur…
C'est vraiment bien, ça ?
Putain, mec, ça faisait longtemps que j'avais plus…
Sur Apple TV. Apple TV+.
…ouais, ça faisait longtemps que j'avais pas vu autant de nuances dans une série, quoi. C'est incroyable. C'est vraiment des points de vue qui sont intéressants, qui sont pertinents.
T'as vraiment les différentes sides of a story. C'est… oh là là, qu'est-ce que ça fait du bien, putain. C'est vraiment, vraiment…
Et ça parle un peu de l'ère post #MeToo dans le monde de la télé…
Ouais.
…et des news.
C'est ça. Et en fait, c'est un peu ce truc de : ouais, mais objectivement, la frontière est floue entre, genre, je couche avec quelqu'un de mon boulot, mais est-ce qu'il y a eu abus de pouvoir ou pas ?
Genre comment est-ce que tu le sais, en fait ?
Mmh.
Est-ce qu'à partir du moment où y a hiérarchie, y a abus de pouvoir ? Bah non. Et du coup, y a vraiment cette… ouais.
Attention, Fanny, tu exprimes une opinion.
Bah ouais. Mais c'est parce que je veux pouvoir coucher avec mes boss, en fait. C'est… Mais non, du coup, c'est…
C'est toi ton boss.
Bah écoute, ouais, c'est ma vie sexuelle. Donc voilà, c'est vraiment très intéressant et très nuancé.
Cool. Super. Bah merci Fanny pour cette reco. Et merci d'être passée. Merci de m'avoir dépanné dans cette période de confinement où je ne peux pas sortir interviewer des gens.
Et oui, je suis la seule à avoir un micro chez moi.
Fanny, salut.
Merci à toi, Guillaume.
Et voilà, c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode. Une petite précision : Fanny m'a envoyé un message il y a une heure pour me dire qu'elle n'assumait plus du tout sa reco de The Morning Show.
Elle n'avait pas terminé la série au moment où on a enregistré cet épisode et visiblement, elle a bien révisé son jugement en voyant la fin.
Si vous découvrez 70 Minutes Avec aujourd'hui, n'hésitez pas à aller faire un tour sur la page de l'émission. Il y a plein d'anciens invités qui pourraient vous intéresser.
Au hasard, je pense à Dan Gagnon, avec qui j'avais passé un très bon moment, à Julie Dachez qui nous a parlé de ce que c'est d'être une femme et d'être autiste, ou encore à Olivia Gazalé, avec qui on a déconstruit le mythe de la virilité.
Tous les liens sont dans la description. Et enfin, je vous en parlais en début d'émission, je galère pas mal en ce moment pour trouver des invités.
Donc, si vous avez la moindre idée de personnes intéressantes qui seraient dispo par Skype, n'hésitez vraiment pas à me faire signe.
D'ailleurs, si vous-même, vous avez un parcours atypique et que vous pensez que ça pourrait peut-être faire un sujet, faites-moi signe aussi.
À très bientôt. Salut.